We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. Here's
a question about a Trump resignation that
has been coming in regularly.
Let's take a listen.
Hey, David, I was just wondering if there
is any validity to the idea of Donald Trump
resigning, Mike, since being sworn in and
then pardoning him for his crimes, sort of
like what happened when Richard Nixon left
office, Gerald Ford clean the slate, Richard
Nixon.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, there's there is validity
to the idea.
It's something that could happen.
I don't think it's very likely.
And I know a lot of you were wondering about
this.
The idea would be Trump anticipates that he
could be in legal trouble after leaving office.
The way to preempt that would be he resigns
and Mike Pence gives him a preemptive blanket.
Pardon.
The reason I think it's unlikely is because
it's just something that's so rare in American
history.
That doesn't mean it couldn't be done.
So if you if you gave me just an even odds
bed and you say, David Bête, does Trump resign
and have pense.
Pardon him or not?
I bet that it doesn't happen if you tell me
to put sort of a number on it.
My thought is that there's like an eight to
10 percent chance that something like that
happens.
Now, many things happen in the world that
have an eight or 10 percent chance.
So these could certainly be famous last words.
But I don't think that it is a likely thing
to happen in the next 10 weeks.
Could be crazy.
So really anything could happen.
But if you if you put me if you hold a gun
to my head and say, David, Bête, does this
happen or not?
I bet that it doesn't happen.
We will have a fantastic bonus show today.
It turns out that Chad Wolf actually did not
have the authority to restrict the DACA program,
which has been the subject of much controversy
during the Trump presidency.
A federal judge has ruled in that way.
We are also going to talk about Deutsche Bank
suggesting a five percent privileged tax on
people choosing to work from home.
I am against that and I will tell you why
on the bonus show.
And we will also talk about how there are
many Obama former Obama staffers who are suggesting
to Joe Biden he needs to go wild with executive
orders to undo the damage done by Donald Trump.
And, of course, you know that the moment Joe
Biden tries to do that, the same Trump ists
who loved Trump's orders, executive orders
will say, oh, that's that's authoritarian.
Using executive orders is authoritarian.
We're going to talk about that and much more
on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.